well our beloved circus circus
officially released their full schedule
of circus shows for the first time since
the pandemic and rocky is
their newest act so grab your popcorn
and enjoy the show
to the world famous circus circus
today starring rocco
[Music]
and rocky
back on rocky rock and rocky we're the
new axe here
at circus circus yay the full schedule
of free circus acts here at the world
famous midway this is a little different
now because during the pandemic
obviously they had
limited shows
oh yeah i'm excited about it everybody's
excited about it
we're in vegas it's going to open up
again baby oh my gosh
absolutely we are excited we've got
people already sitting down waiting for
the next
show to start so rocco what kind of
shows can people catch here daily
oh well you can see the trapeze hacks
you can see the jugglers
you can see contortion you can see
everything you want to see when you come
here what kind of stuff do you do you
told me you're a physical comedian
what do you say i mean that means i do
things physically i'm not a joke tell
anything like this hi oh my god
that's physical comedy it is you're
hilarious right now you're hilarious
so naturally i think since i'm on stage
i should learn a thing or two yes you
should i should i would say juggling
hey guys okay you're going to teach me
how to juggle yes
okay you guys are doing the cool stuff
but i don't think i can handle that
okay rocco yes you got to talk
to me through this you coach me yeah one
two
three oh oh you're too close so close
so close oh shoot okay try one more time
one more time
one two three oh look at that oh
oh how about that did i get a round of
applause
my fish can't even do that all right
i'm just letting you guys know that the
free circus shows are back memorial day
weekend they start
the full schedule is here so on the hour
every half hour
now rocky it's every hour on the half
hour oh
you're cute you're good for something
rocco come on down
bring your family oh my gosh excuse us
excuse us
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you so much rocky we're going to
check back in with you during the 4 p.m
that's good i'd like to see the two of
them together that's a great idea that
is a show to take on the road for sure